what are the common errors committed by
Muslims whilst they're celebrating ID
there are some errors which are
committed by many Muslims some due to
lack of knowledge some due to ignorance
for example there are many Muslims who
think that if they pray in the night
during Eid if they pray the Salah then
the day when Hearts die this is actually
a Hadith which some people think it is
sah but it's not so
that the prophet said that if you pray
in the night of the Eid your heart will
not die the day when Hearts die if you
see I two isnads one of them is very
weak that is J and the other is so it's
totally wrong for anyone to pray during
the night of the E thinking it will get
him Saab to single out that night only
for praying is not allowed unless a
person is habituated for praying in the
night and then prayers it's no problem
but to single out the Eid night only for
prayer it is wrong furthermore there are
some Muslims who visit Graves during Eid
thinking it is good during each day see
visiting grave according to the of
prophet wasallam it reminds you of your
but to single out one particular day and
visit the grave during that day is not
recommended there's no Hadith which
shows us that the sahab mam visited the
grave during Eid to single out during
Eid there to visit the grave it's not
there in the sunah of the prophets and
further
some people they miss the jam which is
very wrong and they miss the Salah
during each day which is totally wrong
as our Prophet mallam said of book of
Faith Hadith number
2621 where Prophet mallam said that the
Covenant between us and you is prayer
and anyone who forsakes it is a kafir
Salah is very important offering jamama
is important furthermore that mistake
that people make normally is that
there's too much of intermingling of the
Sexes men and women even when they go
for Salah they don't take care and we
find men and women chatting with each
other they Adon themselves the wom which
is not right in the mingling should be
prevented and for the places where Eid
are offered in the ID or if it's in a
mosque then it should be seen to it that
there are separate entrances for the men
and women equal but separate facility so
that this interm is avoided furthermore
there are some women who Adorn
themselves who put perfume who don't do
hij
now this should be avoided when they
come in front of aam they should be in
hijab they should be properly covered
they should not wear perfume they should
not Adorn them they should not attract
the opposite side the namam if they do
it for the husband alone it's good
alhamdulillah if they do it amongst the
women only no problem but for the namam
it's not allowed it's mentioned the
Hadith
of Hadith number 5129 where the Beloved
Prophet said that any woman who wears
perfume and passes so that people may
smell her perfume
if she wears a perfume and people smell
a perfume it's as good as she's an
adulteress so these things should be
avoided further some of the Muslims
women e day comes they watch movies they
hear songs they sing they dance they
play musical instruments and all these
things are nothing butan you know
watching un Islamic movies listening to
un Islamic songs Etc as beloved Prophet
M said it mentioned s bukari one number
seven in the book of drinks Hadith
number 5590 the prophet said that there
will be a time when there'll be some
people from my umah who will say that
illegal sexual intercourse drinking
intoxicants wearing silk and playing of
musical instruments are Halal is legal
so we have to be careful that we should
not be amongst these people and one more
point to be noted is that many of the
Muslims they're happy that that Ramadan
is over oh now we don't have to fast you
know as though fasting was a burden they
happy because they don't have to fast
they don't have to fast rather they
should be happy that Allah subhana wa
ta'ala made them complete the month of
Ramadan made them fast that should be
right because fasting is worship they
should be happy for that that they were
able to complete rather than be happy
that it was something burden which they
finished so these things Muslim should
avoid